[Applause]
do the cavaliers have magic remaining
here's osmond wow long distance shot
missed it sexton grabs it and puts it in
it's a one-point game 13 seconds to go
his first back after
seven looked a little scrambly there as
sexton not only got to the loose ball
cavs need a three
sexton works on irving trying to get
loose he'll fire
he knocks it down
colin sexton with one second remaining
in overtime
has tied this game at 127.
sexton was trying to get himself loose
lean to his left
and cans it and that was a great he was
able to left
three points controlling the ball but he
was able to collect himself
at the right time
[Music]
they are reviewing to make sure it's at
three clearly colin's feet were behind
the line
and mr sexton has done it again
they are reviewing to make sure it's a
three clearly collins feet were behind
the line
and mr sexton has done it again
got to keep it moving don't get caught
pound
pound sexton for three
straight away with the triple over
harris and the cavaliers have this four
point lead
nance 305 to go
gives the ball to sexton long distance
three he's got another
colin sexton has 34 and the cavaliers
have taken
a seven point lead and kyrie gets like
the
the aftermath but colin doing a great
job
keep smart move the ball get people
involved
and knock those shots down sexton works
on irving fires he's got it colin sexton
has the cavs last
14 points now he's guarded by the
lengthy durant
to shoot colin will he's got another
mercy light him up collinson
down the stretch over kevin durant
colin sexton has the cavs last 17 points
looking for 20. oh my
wow i don't think you can stop him
he's too hot now